おねがいします 心と心象のことを勉強して終わりましたけど
大体心っていうのはどういうものかということは人間にはわからないんですね
理解しにくい 難しいんです
この前たとえで言ったように
この水と水の溶けているものというと
水っていうのは同じもので理解できないんですね
ですから オレンジジュースとかコーヒーとか紅茶とかお茶とか何とか言ったら我々よくわかるんですね
その場合はやっぱりこの水というよりは
この水の中に溶けている成分のことを我々気になってるんです
ですから 世の中で純粋な水が存在するかというと
それは存在しないんですね
どんな水に何かが溶けてます
そういうと全く同じような働きで心があって
心にいろいろ心室が溶けている
一番身近な数で言えば
七つは必ずも入っているんです
ですから 我々の心は理解しようと思えば
それは不可能なこと その代わりに理解できるのは心象なんですね
ですから 怒りがあるとわかるんですね
今怒っているんだと 欲があるとわかるんですね
欲があるんだと 混乱している自分たちがわかる
今は混乱しているんだと
悩んでるとそれをわかるんです
今悩んでるんだと ですから心の感情というものはわかります
ですから この感情って
そこに心はあるだろうというふうなことでしか心をつかめることはできません
ですから 心象の勉強っていうのは実践的には結構役に立ちます
特に瞑想すると心を見ることは不可能だと思いますね
心の代わりに見られるのはこの貪瞋痴やら無貪無瞋痴やら
ありとあらゆる感情の世界は見えてきます
感じていきます そういうことで
この心その定義と理解っていうのは大事です
今日のお話になるこの組み合わせっていうのは
まあそれほど必要でないかもしれません
理解しやすくためのこちらのチャートがありますから
そのチャートの場合は
一つ一つの心を選んだら
その心にどういうどういう心象が入っているかということは
このチャートには入ってます
で それはそれで構いませんだけど
問題はもし我々にもじゃあ心わかりますかと
例えば今自分にはむさぼりの心があるんだと
不善心があるんだと分かったら
今の不善心にどんなどんな心象あるかとチャート見てでも理解することはできますよ
でも心はどんな心とわからないんですから
ちょっと難しいですね
で 心にどんな心象が入っているかっていうことは全部理解するために
このチャートだけ見れれば問題ないです
今の今日の勉強は この心象を見て
その心象はどんな心に生まれますか？っていうことで
今日はこの不善心所なんですね
不善心所は14種類がございまして
アクシレスパナモーホワイリガアノッタッパムウッダッチャンチャーットチャッタールーミーチェーリサカーサッバークサラサーダハラナーマ
そういうのは前も説明しましたけど
不善心所の14の場合はこの4つ
モウハイリガアノッタッパ
それからウッダイト そういう 4つがありますね
モウハっていうのは無知であって
アヒリカっていうのはえっと無惨ですね
これは喜で あ 無惨 無惨
無喜ですね で ウッダッチャっていうのは情報
情報 で まあわかりやすく
別にもうずっと説明しましたからね
今日は説明は入れませんでおりますけども
この 4つは全て不善心所に生まれるんです
ですからサッバークサラサーダハラナといって
不善心には共通しているんですね
これで我々何を理解するかというと
我々の心が汚れていると
悪い心が生まれていると
確実にその悪い心にモーハがあるんだと
アヒリカがあるんだと
アノッタッタがあるんだと
ウッダッチャがあるんだということを理解して
それだけのこと で モーハっていうのは無知であって
智慧がないということで
物事を現象として見る
ありのまま そのまま見る
ありのままを見るって 2つありますよ
ただそのまま馬鹿みたいに見たり感じたりすることと
本当に何があるかとしっかりと知ることとね
で だけど我々は普通の人間というのは 1番目の
そのままもう受け取ったりするんですね
音楽を聞いて ああ すごい綺麗な音楽だとか
あるいは見たくないものを見たら
あれは見たくないとかね
綺麗じゃないとか すぐ決めてしまったりとか
そういうのはもう我々にとってありのままかもしれませんだけどね
それは真理を知るわけじゃないんです
それでとにかく不善心は無知なんです
それからアディカーナ・タッパっていうのは
やっぱり自分やっぱりプライドがないと恥ずかしいこともしたしたがるし
という気持ちであって
ウッタッパっていうのは自分のこと
やっぱり自分を大事にしないっていうことなんですね
自分を大事にする人は自分を守ると
ですから恥というものを知ってるし
アヌタッパっていうのは怖くはないということで
何でも悪いことを平気でやってしまうと
それも自分を大事にしてないんだからなんですね
だから殺人やらいろんな悪いことする人々っていうのは
決して自分を大事にしようとは思わないんですね
で そういうことで まあですから
不善の心を持ってるその人は自分を大事にしてない
ウッダッチはもっと大事なポイントで
ウッダッチは情動であって混乱した状態なんですね
ですから いつでも心が悪いことをすると
その人は混乱しているんですね
落ち着いてないんです
で 我々踊ったり歌ったりする時でも
心は決して統一してないんですね
かなりの混乱状態です
で そういうことをしたりするんですね
であまりにも欲で感激したりすると
結構心は混乱状態なんです
物事を見えないっていうことはよくあることで
我々この感情が激しい時はそれで気持ちよくやってるかもしれません
例えば ある人をすごく好きになったと
好きになったところで
すごい激しく好きになったら
もう他の何も見えなくなっちゃうんですね
世の中の男も何 1人とも見えなくなってしまっちゃうんです
で それも目が見えなくなったような状態で
ですから それはもう欲の心だから
はっきりとウッダッチョという機能
情動という機能が働いているんです
ですから この怒りで怒りの感情で
あの 何て言いますか 抑えられている人も
欲の感情で抑えられている人は
何言っても聞いてくれないんです
理屈 論理から論理的な状態から心はもう外れてしまうんですね
それはなぜかというと
ウッダッチョという心性が働いているんですね
だから怒ったり泣いたり
ものすごく楽しくて笑ったり
遊んだりする人々には
もう何も理屈も論理も通らないということはなぜかというと
ウッダッチョということが入っている
そのウッダッチョの反対の心性は一強制というか
やっぱりサマーディなんですね
このこのテキストっていうのは
もうそんなにもうアビダンマと言ったっても
アビダンマかどうかちょっと疑問なんですけど
このこれ学生向けに書いたっていうので
世界中アビダンマといえばこれ勉強するようになってるんですよ
でもアビダンマという本当のアビダンマでは
この本当に特別にすごく大事にサマーディの心性っていうのを扱っているんです
こちらはサマーディという心性は全然出てこないんです
まあそこはいろいろ問題ありますけどね
ですから そちらへ出てこなくても
このウッダッチョという心性のものすごい正反対の心性はサマーディなんですね
統一性なんですね 落ち着いていることなんです
ですから 全く落ち着いてないということで不善心になっちゃうんです
で その4つはどんな悪いこと心にもあります
すぐに出てくるのはローバ・ディッティ・マーナという三つなんですね
ローバ・ディッティ・マーナという三つですね
ローバは貪りで ディッティはいろんな意見を
自分のいろんな意見を持ってることと
マーナっていうのは高慢で自分を測ってみる
他人と比べてみる 比べる働きなんですね
自我に基づいて私がいると思ってしまって
私を他人と比べてみる働きはマーナで
ディッティっていうのはまたそこで自我が
エゴがあって 私はこれはこうだと思ってる
これは悪いだと思ってる
これはいいものだと思ってるとかね
ものすごい判断するんですね
現代の心理学的な言葉を使うと
やっぱりこちらで働くのは人間の判断したがる
決めつけたがる性格なんですね
何でも決めつけたがる
あの人はこういうものだ
この人はこういうものだとか
私はこういうものだとかね
いつも判断したがること
で マーナの場合は エゴに基づいて自分をいつでも比較したがる性格
いつでも比較したくなる
誰か誰かと そういうのは全部仏教から言えば悪いものなんですね
他人と比較する必要もないし
何かについていつでも判断しようとしてやろうではないかと
何か決めつけてやろうではないかという気持ちも
決して智慧の働きではないんですね
ローバっていうのは基本的なことで
すぐもう ものを見たら欲しがったり好きになったりという欲
貪りなんですね それわかりやすい
その三つは あの よく 貪瞋痴
貪瞋痴 八があります 八
八種類があります で そこに生まれるんですね
その中で漏婆という働きが貪瞋痴の八にも入ります
で ローバっていうのはどういうものかというと
我々は見るもの 聞くもの
かじるもの 味わうもの
体で感じるものと考えるものという六つ
三つ 六つありますから
それについてとらわれる
受け入れたくなる 例えば音を聞いて
いい音やと受け入れる場合はローバなんですね
貪りなんですね ああ綺麗
聞いて まあ聞きたくない音やと
うるさい音やと思う 音だと思うと
それ自分が拒否する ですから
我々生きている場合は拒絶反応する場合は怒りであって
拒絶反応代わりに受け入れる
何でも受ける反応するとそれはローバであって貪りでありますね
ですから 生きている間はいろんなものについて受け入れる感情がローバであって
その時はローバの心は八種類あります
八種類もその受け入れるっていうことはあります
で 受け入れた人が判断したりしなかったりする
いつでも判断するっていうわけじゃないんです
そこで物事をエゴに基づいて判断するときなんですけどね
エゴに基づいて判断するときはディッティが生まれる
そこでディッティが生まれる心は四つ
四つあります この八の中で四つ
それはディッティガサンといったという心の四つがございます
その四つにそれが入るんですね
ディッティガサン 悪見
悪見想悪見想という言葉でこのテキストに出てくるんですね
悪い見ということで 悪見と書いているのは
この見 正見に正見と差をつけるためなんですね
ディッティは厳密に訳する場合は見だけでもいいんですけどね
まあどのようと判断することだからね
でお釈迦様はもう何のものについて判断をしないんですね
判断しないんだからといって
スケプティックというのを日本語でやります
スケプティック あの ドイツ語ではこういう風に書きますけど
英語になると スケプティシズム
スケプティックそれでもいいんですけどね
スケッチではないんで
スケプティックっていうのはもう全部疑い
懐疑 懐疑主義 懐疑主義ですね
で 懐疑ではないんです
お釈迦様しゃべってましたからね
で 判断できることを判断します
でもヨーロッパではこのスケプティシズムという言葉がございまして
この懐疑主義なんですね
で それはインドでも昔
お釈迦様の時代でも大変発展してあったんですね
懐疑主義っていうのは
何も信じません すべてを疑うと
で そういうのは仏教から見ると無知から生まれているんであって
智慧から生まれるものじゃないんです
でも よく見ると結構似ているところ
ケがものすごくあるんです
仏教の世界でも 仏教で言ったっても
お釈迦様の世界ではね
仏教といえば邪見だらけでちょっと困りますけど
釈迦さんの教えでは お釈迦様の考え方でも
これこれともうしっかりと言えないんですね
例を言うと ある何て言いますか
ある商人が出てきて で
こう言ったんだよ 私はこの商売は仕事を通して一番いい儲かるものだと思ってるんだと
農業はダメだと まさかというと
農業やってるとものすごい大変だと
でも商売は簡単で また儲かるんだと
お釈迦様はそれに私はそう思ってないんだと
私の考え方は 農業も仕事をたくさん仕事あるかもしれませんだけど
うまくいけば結構儲かるんだと
商売にしたっても きちんとノリに乗ってうまくいけば儲かるんであって
ちょっと間違ったら大損するんだと
それはそう思ってない
そこでお釈迦様はちゃんと喋ってるんですよ
じゃあどっちがいいかと言ってるかというと
そう言ってないんですね
商売の世界にしたっても
それはそれで知恵を絞って
状況判断して きちんと行動して
また外の環境も揃ってないと商売
自分がいくら一人でものすごく知恵絞って商売したっても
社会の状況が揃ってないと商売うまくいかないんだよね
それ全部揃ったらものすごく儲かるんです
農業も同じことで 自分がすごい厳密に丁寧に仕事したっても
社会状況というのは この場合は天気なんですね
天気やら土やら そういう状況揃ってないとまずいかない
うまくいったら農業も結構儲かるもんなんですよ
ベースに一日一年中仕事しなくてもいいし
畑に田んぼにしたっても
ほんのもう二 三週間の仕事でしょうに
一日田んぼを作ったりするし
味噌を入れて それから種まいて
それもうたまたま行って肥料をあげたりとかね
雑草を取ってあげたりするぐらいのことだから
全部条件揃っちゃったら
もう何のことなく もう倍
倍も自分が作物をまた取りますから
ですから ある農業やってる人
僕にこう言ったんですね
自分がもうお金に関係なく
もう農業っていうのはものすごく好きですよと
なぜ好きかというと この不思議で不思議でたまらないんだと
自分たちがほんのちょっとのわずかなことをするんだけど
それからこの自然の中からものすごい財産が生まれてくるんだと
で それは本人にとってはなんかすごい不思議な世界なんですね
ほんのちょっと種植えるだけなんですけど
それから得る実の量っていうのはすごいんですから
ですからこのそこでもやっぱり本人の能力と
それのどれほど自分がそれは使っているかと
それから社会の客観的な条件というのは両方揃ってもらわなきゃいい結果が得られないということだから
農業はいいんですか 商売はいいんですかという
そのお釈迦様も決めません
そこでお釈迦様は単なるスケプティックで懐疑主義で
そんなものは何の意味もない
いい加減にしろという意味じゃないんです
それは知恵で 言葉なんですね
それわかりやすい例なんですけど
他の厳密に難しい哲学的などんな質問したっても
お釈迦様はそういう立場でもうきちんと物事を分析して把握して理解して
それに結論出すか出さないかっていうことはもう自然のものなんです
そこまでしゃべる必要ないんだけど
ディッティっていうのは単なるもう自分好き勝手にわがままで
別に今農業と商売について喋ったような感じではなくて
自分の好みで私は商売はいいんだと思ってますよと
私はもう北海道でもどこでも行って
農業やりたかった あれほど素晴らしいこと世の中でないんですよと
みんな結局極論ですね
東京に住んでいて 東京で何か仕事をしてよ
これこそ東京素晴らしい素晴らしいという人
それは極論で 東京から出て行って田舎に戻っている人々も
またそういう極論で どっちでももうどうかということではなくて
その場合は自分の欲望で判断しようとする
それはケンと呼んで 自分の希望で欲望で判断することだからディッティと呼ぶんですね
そこでディッティっていうのは悪見想という心が 4つありますから
そこに生まれる そこでマナが残りの心に生まれる
残りの心はまた 4つありますね
あれは何といいますか
2番目は？アッケンプソー
アッケンプソーという心が4つありますから
そこにマナが生まれる
マンが生まれるわけ ということは
いつでも我々は判断しない時は他人と自分を比べていますかというと
そうでもないんです だから組み合わせは 3種類なんです
それは後から出ますけど
例えば生きている時は普通に欲が生まれる
別に判断しよう何とかではなくて
美味しいものを食べてると気持ちよくなるし
綺麗な音楽を聴くと気持ちよくなっちゃうし
綺麗なものを見ると気持ちよくなったりするし
それは欲なんですけど
その場合はローバだけ
ローバと前に言った4つ
モーハ アイリガ アヌスタッカ
ウッダッチと4つとローバと5つがつけている
それだけ そこでローバに基づいて欲に基づいていろんなことを判断しようとするときは
それに6番目にディッティもつなげるんですね
要は心所は6つ 不善心所が6つつけるんです
それだけ それでエゴに基づいて他と自分を比べる時に限ってマナが生まれる
ですからディッティが生まれたり生まれなかったり
マナが生まれたり生まれなかったりということですね
同じ心にディッティとマナ両方は生まれません
一つの心には一つの働きしかできないんです
例えば何かを判断しながら
その瞬間で自分と他人を比べることはできない
それは次の心をやるかもしれません
ですから この瞬間の心のこと言ってますから
瞬間では一つの仕事しかしないんです
じゃあそれだったらローバという仕事をしているのではないかということはありますけどね
じゃあローバという仕事をしながらどうやってケンという仕事できますかと
そこら辺はあまり説明ないんだけど
そこら辺ではこの似ているものは一つに
何て言いますか 合わせて一つの仕事をすると
ローバとディッティが組んでケンの仕事をする
ローバとマナが組んでからマンの仕事をする
そういう風になる まあ次に
それはそれで終わり 次にはこの怒りの要素ですね
このドーサ イッサ ドーサっていうのは怒り
イッサっていうのは 嫉妬ですからね
嫉妬ですね マッチャリアっていうのは何でしたっけ？物惜しみ
物惜しみ クックッチャっていうのは後悔すること
で この四つ見ても 四つ全部一般的に見ると
この対象を拒否する感情なんですね
で ドーサっていうのは怒りですから
怒りっていうのは対象を拒否する
嫌だと思う だから嫌だと思う瞬間は怒りなんです
イッサっていうのは嫉妬することだから
この嫉妬する対象を自分が嫌なんです
だから嫉妬が生まれるのです
マッチャリアっていうのは物惜しみですから
物惜しみの場合は自分のものを他人に分けてあげたくないということだから
客観的な対象について物惜しみが生まれるんです
この人にあげたくないんだと
この人には親切にしたくないんだと
それはこの物惜しみだから
ケチなんですけど 貪欲じゃないんです
むさぼりの心じゃない
ですから これどうやって
これ例えばいっぱい色んなものを持ってる人が能力やら財産やら誰にも分けてあげない
一人だけで喜んでいると
その人はもう貪欲ではないかと
むさぼりではないかと
我々は誤解 誤解じゃなくて思うんです
ただ人にあげないだけ
それはもう老婆の強烈な状態ではないかと
で そこはマッチャリアかなんかいつでも理解するのは
こういうやり方で理解するんですね
自分の持っている財産だけ見て
これは良かった これは良かったと喜ぶ場合はもう明るいんですね
表面的には よく楽しく食べて遊んで
もう玄関の鍵はもう重にしてかけて
自分だけで楽しく頑張っているという場合は
まあ自分のことだけやってる時は老婆なんですね
でもこれ 他人に分けてあげるのは嫌だと思う瞬間では
その人は暗いんですね
嫌だと あげたくないと
という嫌という感じが生まれてくるんですね
ですから暗いんですね
その暗いのは怒りですから
だから物惜しみをする時は怒り
それしない時は老婆になる
だから一分以内で人間の心の中で何回そういう心が生まれ変わるかっていうのは
これはもうわかったもんじゃない
ものすごい速さで心が変化しますからね
一分以内で老婆の心はもう一万回生まれたりするし
物惜しみの怒りの心はまた一万回生まれるかもしれません
それはものすごい速く変化していますからね
一生同じ性格ということではないんです
で クックッチャは後悔する時ですね
その場合は自分のことを考えて
もう やったことについて
やらなかった方が良かったんではないかと後悔する
あるいはやらなかったことについて
やっておいた方が良かったんではないかと後悔する
それどっちかなんですね
両方過去の過去についてなんですね
あるいは自分の今の状態について気に入らない
現在自分に対して 原因探しちゃうと
あの時それはやって悪かったということで
今の状態 自分の気に入らない
例えば犯罪を起こした人がものすごく悩んでいるということは
もう悪いことをしたんだからと悩んじゃうでしょ
それは後悔なんですね
ですから 今の状態が自分が気に入らないだけ
悪いことをした時は別に
その時自分のことを気に入らなかったわけじゃないんです
ですから 今の状態が気に入らないということで怒りになっちゃうんですね
それでどのように生まれるかというと
ドーサはこの二つの心がありますね
親根心二つあります その二つにもドーサがあるんです
怒りがあるんです いわゆる対象を拒否する
嫌という感情が確実にあります
そこで嫉妬するときはドーサとイッサ
二つが生まれるんですね
物惜しみをする時はドーサと物惜しみ二つが入っちゃうんです
それからなんていうんですか
後悔するときは後悔と怒りが一緒にセットになるんです
だから怒りの心には心所一つ
心所は一つか二つ その心所一つか二つで怒りの心を決めるんですね
で あまりこのあのあの不善
あの心所四つはね 前いた四つは当然ありますけど
その四つとこれ五つか六つですね
悪い心所が だから悪い心所が五つか六つ繋がって怒りの心が生まれる
そんなたくさん心所がないんです
ないんだけど 怒りはどんどん強烈になっちゃいます
強弱の問題があります
この我々はいい人だとかね
よくできてる人だっていうのは
この悪い心所は弱いだけのことで
もう悟ってるわけじゃないんです
悟り開いたらそういうのは消えるんです
そこまではあるんです
でも世の中で犯罪者がいて
もう大変世の中の道徳を守っている立派な人がいると
じゃあ立派な人にこういうことないかというと
そういうことじゃない
必ずありますよ いくら立派な人であろうと怒ったりはするし
物惜しみするし 後悔もするし
でもその人々の場合は
この心所の強弱の場合はもう弱ですね
弱いです 犯罪者の場合はこの不善心所っていうのはすごい力強く活動する
力強く心所が活動するために必要な条件というのは
長い間熟練していることなんです
だから怒りは長い間怒りを養うと強烈な怒りの人になるんです
長い間嫉妬し続けると
この嫉妬心がすごい強烈なんです
それだけのことで それで怒りっていうのは強烈になるとかなり体に悪いんです
怒りからこのすごい悪い
なんて言いますか 物質
化学物質がね 心に生まれますから
体の心も壊れていっちゃうんです
脳細胞も体の細胞も壊れていくんです
ですからもう制限はあるんですよ
これ以上怒りませんと
だから自分を燃やすことだから
もう自分を焼くことだからね
どこまでも焼けるということはできないんですね
まあ死で終わっちゃいますからね
人をいじめようってあげようと思ったって
もう制限があるんですよ
その人をいじめという最高ないじめっていうのは
もう最高というか最低というかわかりませんだけど
その人を殺すことなんですね
それ以上その人いじめをしようと思ってもできないんですね
ですから この怒りっていうのは
その人を死ぬ瞬間 死ぬかもしれない
心臓発作起こしたりとかね
で それぐらいは強烈にはなるんです
よくでも人が死んじゃうんです
あの 本当かどうかわかりませんだけど
突然もう大きな宝くじ当たったとか話聞いてすぐ心臓発作起こして死んだりとか
話はもう聞いたことはあるんだけど
その場合はあまりにも喜んで自分には想像してなかったと
当たるだろう 当たるということは想像してなかった
それで当たったと思った瞬間で
まあどうしようもなくなっちゃって死んじゃうということは
まあ話は聞いてますけど
実際にまあ  [背景雑音]あかりが点灯だけど
そこで次の心 心所二つはティーナ・ミッダなんですね
で ティーナとミッダ これは昏沈睡眠なんですね
ミッダっていうのは眠気であって
ティーナっていうのは
こう 何て言いますか この心が硬くなって行動できなくなるという硬い状態なんですね
心と体の ですからいつでも一緒なんですね
一緒なんですけど それを分けた方がいいなと私は思いますけど
分けた方がいいっていうのは
この 別に眠気までいかなくても
なんか行動したくないというかね
動きたくないとかね 硬い状態があることはありますけどね
でもその状態があるとすぐ眠気が出てくる
だからミッダはこの眠気が出る前のちょっと状態はミッダが強烈なんです
眠気が出たらもう何もわからなくなって
もう眠ってしまいますからね
そこでこの眠るっていうのは
この まあ決してこの人間はこの夜寝ることはそこにティーナ・ミッダとしては入ってないんです
一日仕事をして あるいは体に疲れが溜まったところで
あの ちょっと休んだ方がいいと
と休むのはもうしっかりした休み方だから
それは朝であろうが昼であろうが午後であろうが夜であろうが関係なく
それは問題ないんです
それは無知な 無知だけの人々っていうのは
やっぱりまあいつでもこの寝るということはなっちゃうんですね
それ慣れたら心がいつでも寝る
それはもう治らなく 投棄になってしまう
ですからこの禅宗の場合は
この慣れることを熟練することは一番この大事なポイントなんです
ですから 悪い心所でもずっと引き続けていっちゃうと
もう一緒になってしまうんですね
なかなか取りにくい 同じくいい心所も同じことなんです
長い間いい心所を育てると自分と一緒になってしまうんです
だから嫉妬はずっと続けちゃうと強烈
嫉妬の人間になってしまって
もうそれこそ生きがいになっちゃうんです
嫉妬することの生きがい
怒りで怒り自体が生きがいにしている人々いるんですね
怒りなければ取っちゃえばその人に何もなくなっちゃうんです
物を惜しみ生きがいにしてる人々いたったり
欲が生きがいにしてる人々いたりで
それはもう欲を長い間成長させるんだから
で 世の中でこの教育やら仕事やら
もう全てこの欲を生きがいにしたり
あるいは怒りを生きがいにしたりするようになってるんですね
ですから 現代社会では
このどこ見たっても問題だらけで
問題ないというところはどこにもない
それで答えも出てこない
今もこの子供の問題 どうしますか
ああしますかとかね まあよく喋るんだけど
もうだから全然喋る人も分かってない
なぜこういう問題が生まれてくるかということ
ですから 自分で分かってないことの解決法はあるわけじゃないし
そこで解決法あっても
日本では何か新しい何かやろうとすると
それは年ぐらいかかっちゃうんですね
すごいこうそこら辺でも怠けというか
日本の法律では何であろう
なかなか変われませんね
これ くたらない法律でも変わることすごい
例えばこの結婚しての女性はこの旧姓ででも通ってほしいとか
何のことないんだから
ベースに それまだ通ってないんですね
法律は まだすごい深く考えなくちゃいけないんだと
僕にはそういう人々を見ると
もうこれほどバカかアホかと
昨日の夜もぶん殴りたくなったんですね
ある若い人が この時ぐらいだから殴らなかったんですけど
この であの 僕はコインランドリーに行って衣類を洗っていたんだけど
それであのアメリカ人の女の子
女の人をあげて まあ洗濯は
あの 何て言いますか あれ
外野に入れて それで見ていて
そこでもう彼女はしゃべりゃしゃべりゃ
また男の人も連れてきたんですね
ものすごいでっかい声でしゃべるんで
それはとにかく私を気を引いてほしかったんだよ
女の人は何か私も外人だから何か喋るな
僕はきれいに英語わからないふりをして
で まあ本を読んでいたんですね
でもいくらふりをしてたって耳にこれ入るんだから
どうしようもないんですね
そこでまああの男の人が何とか何とか言って
それ聞いたらこいつぶん殴ってやった方がいいと
これほどアホかバカかと
世の中のこと知らないかと
でも関係ないんだから
まあやっぱりそういう連中はまあ殴ってもいいと思ったんですね
それぐらいもうもうむちったんですね
だからいくらか英語を喋るだろうと
まあ英語を喋るんだから
そういう女の人をそっちやっていくでしょうし
まあただそれだけのこと
それで威張って 世の中の知識やら生きることは英語で生きるわけじゃ
英語で単なる言葉だから
生きるために必要な英語でも日本語でもなくて
違う知識でしょうに 全くない
で もし私知ってる人だったらさんざんいじめると思いますよ
もう何にも知らないあんたっていうこと
ですから この そういうこのちょっとしたことにしたっても
もう判断能力なくて だから判断能力ない人に限って
これすごく考えなくちゃいけないんだ
あーだこーだとかね 知識能力がある人は
これはこれで これはこれですぐ決められるし
ですからこの法律にしてもなかなか変わらない
変えてもいいのに で そういう風に
例えば子供の問題にしたっても
なかなかいくらトラブル起こしても何にもしない
何もしない あの面白かったのは
この学校のこの制度はね
あの5 日制度にしようということで
もう何年経ってるんですかね
あれ 提案出てきてからまだ何もないと
あれでよくもこの国はやってるなと思いますよ
だから外国から圧力をかけないと何も動かないんですね
地雷の問題にしても いろんな外国からとことん圧力をかけられたところで
まあ徴兵制は でもものすごいビビってるんですね
それでいいかどうかとか
だから だからなぜそうなるかというと
やっぱりこの貪瞋痴しかないんですね
小さい時から 違う感情
別に人間悟ってないんだから
貪瞋痴あるのは当たり前
どんな どんな人間にも
それは別に問題ないんです
でもやっぱりヨーロッパにしたっても
むさぼりだけじゃなくて
愛ということも世の中にあるんだと知ってるんだから
自分が儲かるだけじゃなくて
人を助けることも神様はもうやってくださいと言われてるんだという
もう概念だけでもあるでしょうに
そこでいくらか何か決断したり判断したりすることはできるんです
だからこの じゃあ地雷やめましょうということは
もう大きな国には何のことなくやめましょうと大胆にも決められるし
アメリカは言いませんけどね
アメリカっていうのは世界一の強力団体だから
まあ別に ですから アメリカと日本だけなんですね
まあ中国は立場また違いますけどね
ですからやっぱり問題です
すぐ決める能力とかね
そういうのはやっぱり貪瞋痴だけだったら出てこないということを言いたがってるだけなんですね
僕は ですから このまあ
いつでも混乱状態で